[Music]
72 year old announcer brent musberger
he went on and on about alabama
quarterback aj mccarron's girlfriend who
was sitting in the crowd i just kept
talking about her uh and people that was
a little weird here's the actual clip
you see that lovely lady there she does
go to auburn i want to admit that but
she also miss alabama and that's aj
mccarron's girlfriend okay wow i'm
telling you quarterbacks you get all the
good-looking women that's a what a
beautiful woman wow he's aj's doing whoa
some things right then if you're a
youngster in alabama start getting the
football out and throw it around the
backyard with pops
[Laughter]
well yeah a lot of people today are
saying that must burger came across as a
pervy old man
i felt bad about the whole thing i
thought we should talk to brent
mussberger right now and let him clear
the air and what better way to do it
than with a telephone
on a moving pedestal
no one's done this since 1958
on television we didn't even bother to
put wires in the back
oh wait oh there are wires there but
still it's like i have a microphone here
how are we going to talk to brent we'll
ah here we go
good thing we have the old telephone
machine
anyway
we have them on the line right now uh
please welcome brent musberger
hey there brent hey there golden okay
you got to tell us what happened last
night well ken and i may have gotten
carried away but i just call him as i
see him i apologize if i offended anyone
and it won't happen again all right well
thank you very much brent we appreciate
it hey you know why you have me on the
phone uh let's check out your studio
audience
wow
oh man that is a beautiful woman is this
a hen house in the summer because that
is one hot chick
you don't know her that's inappropriate
please okay who else you got what do you
mean oh god wow
look at her if you could see me right
now i'd be called for illegal use of the
hand oh for god's sake
that's disgusting stop it hey okay who's
the next honey oh stop it
holy touchdown yowza mama jama
that's a piece of tail there for god's
sake
hey honey leave some blood for my heart
okay
i'm referring to my erection
just wanted to be you know didn't want
to be too subtle
that's enough brent allen's uh that's
our director stop cutting to pretty
women in the crowd please just stop it
oh
no
not usually the way i go but i'm all
horned up and little brent is not picky
i would definitely do that guy no no
all right that does it i'm hanging up no
sorry
unbelievable
[Music]
unbelievable
what the hell is wrong with that guy i
don't he's been a broadcaster wow he is
hot too
i'd penetrate his secondary
wow i'd toss a hail mary into his end
zone
mr musburger really come on buddy how
about a must burger with extra sauce all
right
i'm confused brent i hung up on you
where where are you talking to me from
i'm up in the rafters conan
right up here
see
yeah
just it's a sweet view from up here i
can see down everyone's shirts
wow it is a sea of hot racks down there
that's fine thank you we're going to
take tell you those jugs aren't full of
gatorade shut up
wow we've got a great show tonight i've
been snorting cialis all right
and drinking that beer for dog shut up
why is he naked
i'm wearing my wife's underwear all
right
we got a great show tonight from the cps
series the big bang theory kaylee cuoco
is on the show wow
i sure would love a nice hot cup of
cocoa all right that's
awful pun uh the knit from the new film
gangster squad very funny guy anthony
mackie's on the show
all right
i'm in a swingers group called the
bangster squad all right
i hate you
i hate myself